I applied to the city in early 2014 to
turn my coin-operated laundry into
housing we sit at ground zero of anti
gentrification in San Francisco getting
this property approved is so far taken
longer than it took the United States to
win World War two
I've spent 1.2 million the Board of
Supervisors denied the project because
it casts a partial shadow on an adjacent
school yard if you're wondering why
housing in San Francisco is expensive
they make it expensive here it is
intentional
[Music]
skyhigh rents in San Francisco it pays
$7,000 a month 54% increase it's just
been such a study client dramatically in
the last five to ten years it's
astounding a sky-high new record once
working-class neighborhoods transformed
San Francisco has become the most
expensive city to live in in the nation
as its population has boomed over the
past few decades developers have found
it almost impossible to build new
housing the story of one small developer
in particular shines a light on what's
gone wrong in the Golden Gate City San
Francisco is the worst place in the
country to try to do development and the
mission is the worst place in San
Francisco
Bob Tillman has owned a coin-operated
laundromat here in the Mission District
for 20 years
in 2013 he decided to tear it down and
build an eight-story 75 unit apartment
building since nobody lives above the
laundry the project wouldn't displace
any residents it would also be in a
popular area near multiple public
transit stops which qualified it for a
streamlined approval process under state
law and the site had another major
advantage for avoiding red tape it was
already zoned for housing if you can't
build here then you can't build anywhere
but San Francisco developers are
required to get explicit permission from
city officials for any new construction
so in early 2014 Tillman began
submitting paperwork to the Planning
Department I went through an
environmental review application for
conditional use permit a Planning
Commission hearing which turned into a
second Planning Commission arranges the
Commission ordered a detailed historical
review based on a claim that various
community groups had offices on the
property in the 1970s and 80s the
resulting 137 page study concluded that
the laundry did not merit historic
landmark status that study cost me
$23,000 and delayed me another four
months in late 2017
the Planning Commission was finally
ready to vote on Tillman's project three
and a half years after he first applied
to build but that's when the real fight
started the mission is the place where
you have the biggest and most vocal an
identification proves
[Applause]
city law says that any individual or
group no matter where they live can pay
a 617 dollar fee to appeal a decision by
the Planning Commission in this case the
challenge came from an organization
called kya bandy Quattro welcome to
priority Quattro Latino cultural
district
--kavitha Quattro has been actively
involved with development the LCD and
greater mission to make sure development
is equitable and that it truly benefits
and meets the needs of the community
[Music]
the mission is an historically
working-class district where less than
two decades ago residents were mostly
Hispanic but the Latino population has
been shrinking as wealthier white
residents move in and housing prices
here are rising even faster than in the
rest of San Francisco Kyah venti guató
which declined reasons interview request
is one of several neighborhood
organizations dedicated to stopping
gentrification in the mission what they
say is they are defending poor people
that actually building more housing
results in more displacement this is
especially been exasperated by the
increase in high paying jobs that have
come to the city and it resulted in a
construction explosion and displacement
by exclusion there is displacement going
on in the mission Latinos are moving out
of the mission I don't know if anyone's
arguing about that
Todd David is the executive director of
the San Francisco housing Action
Coalition it is much better for the
residents who live there now to provide
housing for people who want to live in
that neighborhood the reason that the
displacement is taking place in the
mission is what we haven't built any
housing there in 15 years people are
going to want to lives in the mission
whether we build housing there or not
when you have people with resources
competing with people with fewer
resources for a limited commodity who's
going to end up with that commodity in
the Mission rent control has allowed
some long-term tenants to stay put admit
rising market prices but rent control
discourages new housing construction and
merely delays the displacement of
residents as soon as a tenant dies or
moves out landlords can raise the rent
as much as they like this project
provides only a minimum number of
affordable units in a sense of
neighborhood that is not inclusive
towards our Latino community rent
control wouldn't apply to Tillman's
project but the city requires that all
new buildings set aside a portion of
their apartments for subsidized
affordable housing in this case 11
percent of the units would be available
only to families that earn less than 55
percent of the area's median income
organizers with diabetic guatrau said
this wasn't nearly enough
they either want to block market right
housing or to get it converted into a
hundred percent for
we're asking for continuance to slow
down the project at Tillman's first
hearing before the Planning Commission
advocates asked for another delay to
work out a deal for him to sell the
laundry to a nonprofit that would use
donations and government subsidies to
build 100% affordable housing if we as a
society are going to say we're gonna
take 12 public dollars and build
affordable housing like I think that is
a lovely utopian idea I don't think it's
realistic David thinks that anti
gentrification groups are forcing their
communities into a false choice if one
is truly an affordable housing advocate
that person should say we need to figure
out a way to speed up the production of
market rate housing because the fees
that we get from market rate housing is
the quickest way that we can fund
affordable housing in November 2017 the
Planning Commission approved Tillman's
project over fierce objections yes sir I
really prefer not to call the Sheriff's
Office
after the commissioners rejected another
delay Kyah venti Quattro appealed the
ruling to the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors who would have the final say
the process would take another seven
months we should do this thoughtfully
because the future of San Francisco and
the mission is at stake Tillman's
hearing before the supervisors finally
happened in June of 2018 four and a half
years after he began the process
activists again arrived in mass and the
proceedings quickly turned ugly these
are the times that each of us must rise
to counteract the terror of rising
fascism
there was an activist at that meeting
who literally told my daughter that she
wished my daughter had been blown up in
the Boston bombing another activist at
that meeting said to one of my gay
supporters publicly we don't want people
like you in the mission go back to the
Castro in San Francisco Oh everyone's
Democrats but we really have two
political parties we've the progressive
political party and we've a moderate
political party the San Francisco
Progressive Party is about as anti
progressive is from a policy point again
they are the party of death they are the
let's pour amber over the city and stop
it's the crisis on Mission Street
upscale cafes coming in
climbing gym on Mission Street what's it
gonna be like five ten years from now if
this was just an issue of bureaucracy it
would be frustrating that doable what
kills you is the political answer all
the other supervisors will back a
supervisor on a project that only
affects that supervisors district and
they all do it
reciprocally for each other nobody's
saying that newcomers and change isn't
welcome supervisor Hillary Ronan who did
not respond to our interview requests
represents the mission in this district
Hillary Ronan is allied with the anti
gentrification groups effectively they
can walk projects they're seeing build
market rate housing but when you build
enough below market rate housing for the
people that that have lived in this
neighborhood that's just like it's
either a true misunderstanding of how
affordable housing gets paid for or it's
pure [ __ ] right I just don't want I
don't want any housing I have not been
singled out this is the playbook that
they use with everybody Tillman says
he's seen numerous other projects
stymied no matter how small the
developer there was a four unit project
at 792 cap Street that literally went
through half a dozen Planning Commission
hearings the project sponsor was a man
named Lucas Eastwood who is a
full-blooded Native American and grew up
on a reservation he employs
predominantly Hispanic building crew and
still he was delayed and harassed
at Tillman's hearing Ronan and the other
supervisors didn't object to any aspect
of his existing application but they
found a new issue that in the over four
year process hadn't yet been raised in
terms of shadows
they denied the project because it cast
a partial shadow on an adjacent school
yard we need another study done so that
way we can confirm that these children
will be able to live and play and
develop in the sunlight the building
would cast a shadow over this playground
[Music]
when the choice between expedited
development and the health and safety of
a child's life the answer should be a
no-brainer supervisor Ronan and the
Board determined that the shadow impact
was a potential violation of an
environmental law called sequa but
according to Tillman such shadows are
not covered by sequa they made up a
sequel ground that doesn't exist under
their own law objectively let's be
honest about this is about getting top
dollar for a piece of property mr. Toman
is exploiting the process for his own
personal gain I followed the laws for
four and a half years I spent 1.2
million dollars following the laws and
now at the last minute they break their
own laws if you're wondering why housing
in San Francisco is expensive that is
why they make it expensive here it is
intentional Tillman considers himself
lucky to have an existing business that
offsets the cost of the delays many
other developers sit on idle properties
as their bills stack up so the question
is well then why do developers kind of
put up with this alright David says that
the Board of Supervisors even commonly
ignores mandates and state law to
streamline the approval process
local officials get away with this
because the only recourse for developers
is to sue the city and that's extremely
rare because they fear retaliation they
can be held hostage on other projects
and the city's laws are complex enough
that that's very easy to do Bob is in a
really unique situation he is a one-time
developer
he's never building anything else in San
Francisco the only reason that I am able
to sue is because I do not have to
constraints on me that other developers
do after the Board of Supervisors were
did his plans Tilman decided to take San
Francisco to court for 17 million
dollars in damages or what he says his
building would have generated thus far
if not for the city's illegal delays
even the people who are against Bob
project readily admit to me
well he's not following the unwritten
rules and I say well you know goods at
that time someone doesn't follow the
unwritten rules
anyone who today is an indie the not in
my backyard movement is clearly on the
wrong side of mr. David views Tillman's
case is just one battle in the housing
policy war that will determine whether
San Francisco continues its
transformation into a cloistered Country
Club or if its future will be as diverse
and welcoming as its past I'm not sure
that one wants to be remembered in San
Francisco
as a person standing up saying I don't
want those people living in my
neighborhood whether they need it's a
policy of exclusion the messaging the
language is changing and that is really
kind of very very powerful the politics
kind of lags behind we have to make
changes to our bureaucratic process that
gets in the way of housing production in
San Francisco in 2018 San Francisco
voters elected mayor London breed who
made a campaign promise to streamline
the approval of new housing but Tillman
views breeds past record as a testament
to how anti development groups have
captured the local political class
that's because less than a month before
she was sworn in as mayor Reid cast one
of her final votes as president of the
Board of Supervisors it was a vote
against Tillman's projects Lee they have
made the building of housing more costly
and more time-consuming and more
uncertain and more difficult in about a
dozen different ways it is far worse
than it was in 2014 when I started we
have to build more housing we have to
build more housing
we have to build more housing but soon
after Tillman sued in August the
Planning Commission delivered a surprise
we asked the shadow consultant to
prepare this it had independently
studied the shadow issue and found that
it wouldn't have a significant negative
impact on the playground next door the
Commission quickly reappeared the
project and key event the Quattro
declined to appeal as of now it looks
like Tillman finally has the green light
to move forward more than four and a
half years after he began still he
hasn't yet withdrawn his lawsuit because
he says the Board of Supervisors is
continuing to devise ways to try to
derail his plans we're in a hole and the
first rule of holes is when you're in a
hole stop digging
[Music]